déguisé en Scream isnel violation du
droit à la vie est en train Valenciennes
les autorités libanaise ont fermé les
yeux face au danger que pour une trappe
d'ammonium entreposé depuis 6 ans dans
un hangar c'est ce qui ressort de
rapport publié par le Angie Human Rights
Watch l'organisme critique la corruption
et la mauvaise gestion des hauts
fonctionnaires et demande une enquête
indépendante de l'ONU
[Musique]
c'est un peu comme on ne ressent pas la
douleur au début mais avec le temps
selon un sondage mené par l'UNICEF une
famille sur 3 à des enfants ayant des
signes de détresse psychologique
s'il est adulte cette proportion atteint
une personne sur deux
d'électricité et
les besoins sont importants 70 % des
familles touchés par l'explosion ont
toujours besoin d'une aide financière et
alimentaire selon l'Unicef
mercredi une conférence de soutien au
Liban sera présidée par Emmanuel Macron
actif mobiliser une aide internationale
de 300 million d'euros ici Radio Canada
Montréal